Vous avez été
nombreux à regretter
que le son ne soit pas de bonne qualité
sur les précédentes capsules.
Avec ce micro,
ça ne devrait plus se produire.
Alors, c’est un tout petit micro,
un micro à condensateur.
Pour comprendre comment
il recueille le son de ma voix,
je vous propose de commencer par regarder
ce qu’il y a à l’intérieur d’un micro classique.
Qu’est-ce qu’il a
dans le ventre ?
Ici,
on voit mieux !
Une membrane qui est fixée à une bobine
de fil conducteur qui coulisse autour d’un aimant.
Maintenant, on va faire une expérience,
regardez cette petite installation.
Quand j’appuie sur l’interrupteur,
l’aiguille de la boussole dévie.
En fait, la circulation du courant électrique
à l’intérieur du fil conducteur
génère un champ magnétique
auquel l’aiguille de la boussole est sensible.
Inversement, la variation d’un champ magnétique
à proximité d’un fil conducteur
induit un courant électrique
dans ce fil conducteur.
Très concrètement,
quand la bobine coulisse autour de l’aimant,
la variation du champ magnétique
induit un courant électrique dans cette bobine.
Quel rapport
avec ma voix ?
Le son,
c’est de l’air qui vibre.
L’air qui nous entoure est constitué de molécules :
principalement de l’azote et de l’oxygène.
21% de dioxygène, 78% de diazote
et 1% de gaz rares.
La vibration de mes cordes vocales, provoquée
par le passage de l‘air qui sort de mes poumons,
entraine la détente et la compression
des molécules qui composent l’air.
Ce mouvement se transmet
de proche en proche jusqu’à nos tympans,
ou ceux des personnes
qui nous entourent, qui se mettent à vibrer.
Les tympans hein… parfois plus
quand la musique est bonne !
On peut observer ce phénomène
en faisant une petite expérience.
Celle-là, je l’ai déjà faite. C’est même
la première expérience que j’ai faite devant une caméra.
J’ai tendu un film alimentaire au-dessus d’un saladier
et j’ai déposé quelques grains de sel.
Maintenant,
ouvrez grand les yeux.
Vous avez vu ? Quand je frappe sur le djembé,
je fais vibrer la peau, qui fait vibrer l’air.
Cette vibration se transmet
de proche en proche
et fait vibrer le film alimentaire
sur lequel les grains de sel s’agitent.
Et mon micro
dans tout ça ?
Le son produit par mes cordes vocales
ou par un instrument
fait vibrer la membrane,
qui fait bouger la bobine autour de l’aimant.
La variation du champ magnétique induit donc
un courant électrique à l’intérieur de la bobine.
Un courant électrique qui module
exactement comme ma voix.
Et à partir duquel on va pouvoir
reproduire à l’autre bout de la chaîne,
autrement dit chez vous,
le son de ma voix.
Le problème avec le son,
c’est qu’il se propage en formant un cône.
Plus il s’éloigne de la source,
moins il est concentré.
C’est pour cette raison
que vous aviez du mal à m’entendre
quand la petite caméra s’éloignait de moi
ou quand je tournais la tête.
Le son de ma voix ne faisait
pas suffisamment pression sur son micro.
Alors que là, sous mon menton,
il est aux premières loges
et capte essentiellement le son de ma voix
et très peu les bruits ambiants.
Eh l’oiseau, il va falloir
chanter un peu plus fort maintenant !
Ce micro est tout petit.
Il est lui aussi équipé d’une membrane,
mais il n’y a pas de bobine ni d’aimant.
À la place, il y a ce qu’on appelle un condensateur.
Il s’agit de 2 petites plaques métalliques
qui conduisent le courant électrique
et entre lesquelles il y a un espace.
Minuscule. La taille d’un film alimentaire.
Le condensateur
est alimenté par une pile.
Quand je parle, le son de ma voix
fait pression sur la membrane
qui est aussi la plaque mobile
du condensateur.
Les plaques se rapprochent
et le courant électrique passe plus facilement.
Au final, le courant électrique
va moduler comme ma voix.
Ca va ? Cette fois, j’ai l’impression
qu’on est vraiment fait pour s’entendre.
Allez, à très bientôt ! J’ai encore
plein d’histoires à vous raconter.
Terminé !
Et je coupe le son…